y nosotros estamos contentos porque esto
significa la regularización de
ciudadanos que estaban en las sombras y
que lamentablemente esto provocaba
varias violaciones a sus derechos como
ciudadanos especialmente en el área
laboral que eran prácticamente
muy explotados nosotros consideramos en
la respuesta por parte del presidente
lazo es muy bienvenida esperamos que el
ministerio de relaciones exteriores y
las demás organizaciones del estado que
van a tener que cumplir o hacer cumplir
esta este decreto lo hagan de forma
efectiva porque evidentemente el aporte
de los ciudadanos venezolanos hacia la
economía formal muchos de ellos están en
las sombras en una economía oscura
seguramente van a apoyar a la economía
ecuatoriana y eso asombra noticias sin
embargo hay un vacío en este decreto
porque la norma aplica para los
migrantes regulares y por lo menos el
62% de los venezolanos que entraron a
ecuador lo hicieron de manera irregular
según las cifras de la agencia de la onu
para los refugiados
es decir que esto dejaría a la mayor
parte de los migrantes por fuera ante
este panorama que tan efectivo es el
decreto
bueno yo creo que todo proceso de
regularización para extranjeros en
cualquier país es importante y si es que
se están quedando fuera como parece que
es de estas circunstancias yo creo que
los acuerdos ministeriales podrán de
alguna forma ayudar para que esto sea
efectivo recordemos que es un decreto
ejecutivo y esto también se puede
cambiar sólo puede mejorar si es que es
necesario y evidentemente las cifras
serán las que determinen a ciencia
cierta cuál es o cuántos son los
migrantes venezolanos y de otras
nacionalidades que también podrían tener
acceso a esta amnistía que ha presentado
el gobierno ecuatoriano y ahora hagamos
una mirada latinoamericana porque
colombia había regulado la migración de
venezolanos con un decreto muy similar
al que hoy adopta ecuador en este
sentido que está cambiando en la región
respecto al tema
yo creo que la perspectiva de que los
venezolanos no van a regresar a su país
por ahora y eso significa de que muchos
están buscando una situación permanente
una regularización tener acceso a
fuentes de trabajo a derechos que muchas
de las veces por ser indocumentados o
por ser extranjero los están
discriminando y que esta vez ya con un
camino a la legalización como un camino
por parte del estado para poder
permanecer de forma legal dentro del
ecuador esto va a permitir de que muchos
venezolanos tengan una oportunidad para
asentarse y poner raíces mucho más
profundas pensando ya a largo plazo
imagino también de que sus hijos sus
familias van a poder ser beneficiadas y
esto en términos generales yo creo que
es muy positivo para la región porque
esto indica también un camino a seguir
para otros países es muy positivo para
el país porque van a fomentarse nuevos
lazos económicos
muy positivo para las familias porque ya
no van a tener esa preocupación de que
quizás mañana me van a deportar